- Health care
vertical for marketing.
- So, I mean--
- So, who's the target?
- Physicians,
doctors, facilities.
- Hospitals.
- What are you
trying to sell them?
- Well, it's our service.
We do a lot of lot of
management for them--
- Yep.
- but now are also
growing it with IT.
- Okay.
- All the products with
networking and all that stuff.
And so--
- Think about it backwards.
Think about
everything in articles.
Why physicians, why hospitals
need to start caring about
privacy and then
write that article.
Why independent physicians
need to understand Snapchat.
And write that article.
I reverse engineer.
Once you start with what you
think they should be thinking
about like whatever IT
you're selling there's a why.
There's a why you think
you they should have it.
- Right, right.
- Don't be the doctor that
loses your patient's data.
- Yeah.
- Article.
Then that article or video
is deployed against
physicians on LinkedIn.
Against physicians on Facebook.
Understand?
- What I am afraid
of with Facebook--
- Go ahead.
- is because the physician--
- Yes.
- is not really into Facebook.
- [Gary] Who says? You?
- Well, I see from my clients--
- Your focus groups of
five or 50 is too small.
- Okay. True.
- You don't think Dr. John
is on fucking Facebook?
- [Man] It's true.
- [Woman 2] You'd be surprised
you start talking to people
you'd be surprised
what they are into.
- All my physicians
are on Facebook.
I have three.
They're all there.
I see their fucking pictures.
They're there as
John not as Dr. John.
Doesn't mean John doesn't see
the video and if John sees why
physicians should start worrying
about data John might read that
when he's having his
coffee on Tuesday morning.
- [Woman] Mhmmm. Okay.
- [Gary] That's the problem.
People make decisions
on their focus group.
Musical.ly's going to be big.
People send me an email, "Well,
my 14-year-old daughter says
"it's not cool anymore."
Mazel Tov but your 14-year-old
daughter is not every fucking
14-year-old in America.
So the data shows that plenty
of doctors are on Facebook.
Probably most of them.
- [Woman] Okay.
Well, thank you.
- You got it.